but I think it's changed I think
everybody's relationship based now back
then it wasn't yeah and when I say I got
killed they used to write [__] about me
and strand like making fun of us they
used to write it they just call you guys
oh man it was [__] no they were not
that but it was oh yeah
all right trying to relate because we
get that the way you said it your voice
your voice
I think I read that story yeah
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
Jay Glazer that was quiet Jay Glazer in
the house ladies and gentlemen it's been
a while A lot's happening you look good
young man I look fantastic three years
younger than me congratulations I
haven't seen you since when I think you
went I think
74.74. it was in 12th grade right it was
it was the Three Mile Island meltdown
yeah uh it's been a while dude five
years no do you know where nowhere you
don't remember no so
we set up this [__] crazy crazy crazy
lunch at Stallone's house I bring Guy
Fieri to [__] cook dude right yep
right right yes we kind of broke the
internet that you know about the [__]
and Frank Grillo was there carilla was
over there Michael Strahan uh uh
I'll tell you real quick sorry so
Stallone says hey uh I just got a 25 000
Grill I'm gonna get a Grill Master come
over teach me how to do it I said why
the [__] would you do that once you get
Guy Fieri he goes really you think you
do that I'm like yeah dude you're Rocky
so he goes yeah yeah yeah yeah
he has no idea right and God's a good
friend of mine so one day a couple weeks
later there's a fight going on it's uh
Anthony Joshua against Ruiz yeah right
and uh Stallone calls and he goes any
chance your friend guy in town uh you
have one come over and watch the fight
and I'm gonna do again uh yeah dude
you're Rocky yeah so I said yeah
actually we're going out to dinner
tonight we're having a dinner it was
like a crazy little dinner with me guy
Mike McCarthy and strayan and and uh
this girl Ava Knight who's fighting for
us right so I said yeah he's coming he
goes well here's the deal any chance you
could bring him because my daughters
really don't care about Rocky or Rambo
but they love diners drivers and dies
any chance you can bring them I said let
me find out so I call up guys to tell me
you love me he said why do I love you
and I said man you know Stallone wants
to know if you want to go come watch a
box of match his outs and and his
daughter's like man they're huge triple
D fans yeah he goes let me let me call
my wife first and see if I can do it
because I'm supposed to go home tonight
he calls his wife Lori Lori says let me
get this straight Glazer is asking you
to go to Stallone's house to watch a
boxing match and you're asking me if you
yeah you gotta do it like yeah she goes
you're a [__] idiot yeah if you come
up there so he calls back he goes all
right tell Stallone I know it just went
fast in this all right
he said uh all right tell Sly I'm in and
I'm gonna make his daughters my Sous
chefs so that's cool find out who's
coming and I'm gonna bring I'm gonna
have the Food Network like load me up
I'm gonna cook and it's going to be
incredible so I said great I called
Stallone I said tell him you love me he
goes why do I love you the synonymous
guy coming he's going to bring all his
food and he's gonna make your daughters
a sous chefs and he goes really he
didn't have to do that I'm just gonna
get cold cuts I said bro you're not
getting [__] messed up guys
cold cuts right here we go old school
[__] Jersey there we go
so he goes no I said bro we're not doing
[__] cold cuts like tell me what the
guest list is he goes all right who are
you bringing I said I'm gonna bring uh
guy and Strahan and uh castran's taking
me he's my baby sister and you know he's
taking me [__] everywhere yeah since
he's become a yeah yeah so I sound like
I gotta I gotta repave he takes me like
the Vanity Fair Oscars party and this
and that I gotta repay him so uh
I said so I'm bringing straight hand guy
I said who you bringing he goes okay so
guest list is uh you strand guy me
Pacino Schwarzenegger Sugar Ray Leonard
I go get out of here he goes what these
are my friends don't forget David Blaine
Cameron he did Magic into a Magic
Kitchen wait we broke the [__] it's
still confused how calm got into this
party
is it because his daughter
uh his daughters are comedy fans so they
they we all were hanging out after the
show and they came up to me and they
were like you were really funny remember
they did a podcast out of the studio yes
they did yeah because before that I
didn't know that they were just really
nice and they said you love my dad and I
go you know he's you know semester yeah
[__] yeah I do yeah but I get to that
I get to that party and I walk in the
kitchen now I'd been to Stallone's house
two times before that for fights and
stuff so this was my third time and so I
get there and I walk in and Guy Fieri
because he knew me whatever he was like
Hey you know Bobo and then he goes
before he even says anything he goes you
got to try this try this he puts a piece
of like meat in my mouth yeah with
truffle oh dude he went really so well
he is guy like it's not just like for
show he's a good thing he's a great guy
down to earth guys he's incredible yeah
I've got a bunch of plays with them
great guys it's like a traveling party
what you see is what you get yeah yeah
by the way by the way party did you guys
have a contest whose backs the worst uh
is he still alone over me
at the studio I'm like bro oh by the way
wrong that day he was uh we're there and
he goes hey uh you think it'd be okay if
I post this on social media I'm like
yeah dude you're Rocky yeah did you do
what the [__] you wanted to switch
we broke the internet it was this
Saturday yeah Saturday everybody in the
NFL is calling like
what is going on what are you doing like
that's the day I usually get away I was
I'm standing in a circle and it's Pacino
Schwarzenegger uh Stallone and uh Sugar
Ray Leonard right and me no no wait wait
wait it's actually misspelled your name
yes they did now here's the best yeah
well
gorilla's there and Joe carnan now now
here's the the best part
um uh Bill Burr walks by me as I'm
listening to these guys he's got a cigar
in his mouth and he goes hey you've been
here an hour already get over it I was
like I'm not over Richard that was a
great day oh the best part was this Jay
um as so see how Frank and and
um Joe Carnahan director uh yeah and
there's oh they're Schwarzenegger so I'm
there I'm sitting with right next to
Dalia and uh and when the fight's on
Sugar Ray Leonard the great Sugar Ray
Leonard is right here and gorilla are
criticizing Anthony Josh it was boxing
and I was like please don't do this
don't do this in the earshot and sugar
razor you know give him a call oh yeah
he's doing he was called commentary and
he was great he was yeah everybody did
not tell them no no he didn't but he
gave me a boxing lesson you would have
been more and more than anybody on video
it's on video where he was showing me
how to go to the body because I said you
know whenever I go this way I get
punched in the face I don't know how to
dig to the liver and he goes and he
starts giving me a lesson and Stallone
says to my girlfriend what are you doing
get this on videotape it's just my
prayer and then Salon gets himself in
the middle as I'm getting a lesson he's
awesome Sly is the [__] best the best
he's coming train with us for a while
and he was just he was in strands here
one day and he was just like you're
you're shelling you're immaturity
unbreakable that's all you're doing you
guys just act like a bunch of [__]
sticks I'm like absolutely yes but yeah
no doubt right he was coming in and
trading that's great great wow this
straight hand train I'd love to see what
he can do yep Michael's trains
constantly yeah yours [__] I'm saying no
not fighting okay
in his career he was like 272 and then
[__] I think it was year 10 or something
he's like all right if I want longevity
I Gotta Lose a bunch of weight and that
we don't need some shirts
and he uh
he went down to like 248 in between
that's how big he is yeah that's trim
for him 248 from 272 but he's like on
his side in my career that's like you've
gotten a 160. like at his size it's
pretty standard yeah all right B let's
take a little break from John with our
boy Jay Glazer because like every
episode lately can we let's get nuts
let's get nuts speaking of mental health
I'm nuts I'm little nuts too but I think
you might be talking about Macadamia oh
I love me that's my favorite nut well it
is it is my favorite knot in fact a
couple nut boys I'm literally eating the
chocolate dipped uh macadamia nuts
um I mean that's all we eat snack on
here oh they're the best they are they
are the most they they have omega sevens
and macadamias are linked to collagen
producing and reducing inflammation
which are key parts of longevity and
world record epigenetic Age reducer
Brian Johnson includes macadamias in his
daily blueprint diet but you would think
a bag of the macadamia nuts cost you two
three million dollars they're the most
how does the house of macadamias make it
so this is a good question friendly they
are the most expensive nut that's a fact
always have been always been a crazy
delicacy not for the rich best no
they're the nuts for the rich not
anymore by the way House of macadamia is
working works with 96 South African
Farmers that makes them more accessible
okay it's farmer owned and uh they can
always guarantee the best quality and
best prices also macadamus has a wide
range of products from yeah there's no
added sugar or artificial ingredients we
love we love the chocolate covered nuts
and listen they don't do a lot of cool
giveaways but for the fire kid listeners
my god did they hook you up all right
they're gonna give you guys some sea
salted macadamia nuts right now all
right instead of the extra virgin oil
they're the they're from the namibian
sea the namibian sea okay I don't know
what that means but Libya is is look up
where the Namibia sea is Salt Lake's in
a bay of nibia yeah dude oh the sea from
Namibia from the Namibia sea yes dude
try to say that baby
wait it's like is this name
just say salted nuts no dude when it's
maybe it's sea nuts that's a whole
that's all from Salt nibia eat well it's
from the ambibia sea no you know it's
all from Narnia may as well be yeah do
you know where the Namibia sea is of
course of course not but I do no me too
show me maps in Africa somewhere maybe
yeah all right instead of the extra
virgin Macadamia Oil they're gonna give
you an entire box of these macadamia
nuts 35 bucks they're worth 35 bucks
with your first purchase go to House of
macadamias.com
tfak you get 20 off your whole order
whether it's the dip macadamias the so
The Salted the bars whatever you're
gonna get 35 bucks worth it's a and the
only ingredient other than macadamia nut
just so you know is the salt from the
beautiful Salt Lakes in
also magnetic just say salted macdarena
so for me next time right nope say
Narnia salt because I will not eat it
unless the salt comes from Namibia do
you know where it's at
that borders the Atlantic Ocean that's
where they're getting their salt from uh
I don't even know if oh they have a
significant cheetah population oh salt
from cheetahs from cheetahs cheetah
sweats they get it from the cheese say
that 10 times cheetah sweat salt anyways
House of macadamias.com
tfak for 20 off your whole order plus
you get the cool salted macadamia nuts
but he but he also it the life he that
he's in now you know being on those Good
Morning America where the hell show he's
on those he's so big so him cutting down
240 seems like once you're in that
business you want to get Slimmer yeah
absolutely and it's I'm with them it's a
longevity thing yeah yeah I've been on
the other way
and then with uh you was talking about
on Saturdays usually when you get the
Scoops with that I think it's it's all
week long but Saturday is when I like
big time I fill in every team that I
haven't called yet and it's all day all
night doesn't stop let's ruin every
relationship I've ever had besides the
current one it just it doesn't stop and
how hectic was the draft free that just
went on is that is
so here's the thing with the draft I'm
the only reporter who doesn't do a mock
draft because I'm not gonna lie to the
fans I hate mock draft well there's
first of all they're stupid because no
one sets their board until the week of
so when people are telling you three
weeks out what A team's doing they're
like they have no clue the team don't
even know they don't have their Boards
out yeah right they didn't finish their
visits all that so and things change
like there was there was a time I'll
never forget Cowboys are calling me on
something they're going to draft Sean
Merriman they were set to draft him man
they've done you know 364 days of work
leading up to this and the morning of
they called said
yeah we think we're changing our minds
what are you doing they said yeah I
think we're going to shift off him and
go to DeMarcus Ware I said what happened
he said just some conversations we had
last night last night last night and
they shifted off merrim in the morning
of and went to DeMarcus Ware and worked
out you started as a reporter Jay yeah
yeah yeah back so man people don't
really know the craziness of my story I
was the first minute-by-minute breaking
news guy in the country when that
internet thing came out which I think is
going to take off yeah and uh I think
there's something to it wow um but my
first it's actually crazy my first um
took me 11 years my first 11 years of my
career I was making uh 9450 bucks a year
living in New York City and how did you
survive well that would talk about
strand he's the first guy I met at
Giants uh practice I became friends with
and I didn't have enough money I was
living in New York City I didn't have
enough money to go take a Subway to a
bus to Giant stadium and back each day
so he drove me back into New York City
he didn't even live in the city every
single day for seven years what a great
guy incredible I own like 28 Grand in
Lincoln Tunnel Fair what a great yeah
and that but the other thing is like I
walked in that giant locker room day one
and I was like man I don't have the same
experience to everybody else I don't
have the same
um
education is everybody else I don't have
any of this stuff but man how could I be
different
so if these guys work nine to five I'm
knocking out working by a little on my
or out working by a lot I will be the
last [__] standing here every
single [__] day I'll be the last
[__] dude standing here because I
also I had to wait for Strahan to drive
me home yeah all right so you had no
choice it worked no no no working as a
reporter I'd sit there man and just
build but the other thing I was trying
to do is I'm like how could I be
different than all the other guys
I fell way back then everybody used
their pen as a weapon I was like well
I'm going to start relationships with
people and I actually got crushed for it
for a while but I wasn't objective
because I was starting relationships
without your bias yeah and I had more in
common with players and coaches than I
did my those other newspaper paper
reporters of course right so you love
the athletes you love the process but
also I was training back then I was like
you know so
um over time though man like I was
rejected more than any human being you'd
ever meet in your entire [__] life it
was
[__] horrible and people think that
that overnight success happens overnight
it happens over 11 years
especially in the NFL any job you want
any any dream you have it's not going to
take overnight that's full of [__] so
man I just kept going kept getting
rejected kept trying to get every job I
possibly could and just kept getting
rejected and rejected but I cut you know
my name kept growing more and more as
man you could trust this guy this guy's
most trusted guy in the all these locker
rooms you can really trust him these
players and coaches and finally man 11
years in I get this call from it I've
been rejected by every agent until
finalists got more guys friends like all
right this guy's all right I took every
free job you could I was on New York One
TV for
to an hour show every week for 450 bucks
a year damn [__] you were writing
right and I was writing and I finally I
got a gig for the New York Post for 250
bucks a story so that was the nine grand
yeah and then and I couldn't go get
other jobs because I had at work
everybody so it's like early on I was
like boxing and bouncing and bartending
and I tried to stand up comedy said all
this anything I could but eventually I
had to put all my time into this so
literally like man I'd be the first one
there and then I'd be there till seven
o'clock at night or whatever and
everybody else left just interviewing
guys and it's starting relationships so
guys leave they leave the locker room
man I just didn't talk to them yeah it
was the key to Jay because he's a
relationship guy so they can trust him
yeah they know he's not gonna out them
like they might give them private
information
right between reporting used to be yeah
yeah and now it's all relationships it's
the only way it happens it's all
relationships but also it's so Cutthroat
what he does like they don't feel like
the breaking news like J breaks a lot of
news because guys like him then there's
the guys on the business side like Adam
Shaffer and those other guys yeah he's
good Adam's good it's super cool yeah
it's like between yeah the guys that
break the news bro guys the business
guys don't like you but the athletes do
yeah yeah yeah no no it's we're all good
now because again I was man I've been
doing it now since 99 yeah is when I got
done well 93 how'd you get into sports
where you just like you played football
high school or something um I wrestled
in high school and then I um where did
you go I got an internship where in
Jersey did you grow up uh Jersey Shore
good wrestling in Jersey yeah great
great wrestling I don't like to use
those guys in New Jersey I just like to
say outside New York City yeah so just
say Jersey maybe just for sure real real
Sports Brian crumble did this feature on
me one year is hey this guy's and this
is when The Insider business really blew
up right it was like Hey this guy's
crazy good his job because he's crazy
and they call my high school principal
or whatever and and they said hey can we
get some high school yearbook photos of
Jay Glazer in wrestling photos and the
guy said who
said Jay Glazer and he said who they
said you know you have a guy who is on
national TV he went to your high school
and they said yeah we know Mike
serrantino The Situation had no [__]
idea who I was but I knew the situation
yeah I was like that is fantastic
that's amazing
wow so if people don't realize the the
back story of it and then
um
you know when that again when the
internet thing came out when I realized
man we don't have to wait for the back
page anymore
um I got to get cbssportsline.com and it
was me versus guy named Lynn pascarelli
and John Clayton Chris Mortensen for
like minute by minute breaking news and
that that kind of really you know that's
something yeah that was every that
changed everything and then I kept
picking fights with ESPN back then and
um and it just became this huge thing
which it is now and over time you were
on the side of the truth though you were
always telling the truth you're trying
to get to that yeah that was different
do you know what I'm saying I was
different I was different too and I was
always [__] with them and trying to
pick fights because and you also were
like clickbaity you weren't screwed no
it wasn't like it was never like like a
lot of the journalists especially back
there were like snakey about it or they
do a story like you know whatever a guy
has some altercation outside of the
field right but I think it's changed I
think everybody's relationship based now
back then it wasn't yeah and when I say
I got killed they used to write [__]
about me and Strahan like making fun of
us they used to write it please oh man
it was [__] no they were not bad but
yeah but it was it was um man it was
again it was just it was it was [__]
brutal and miserable for all those years
and then one day my agent calls and says
hey I was on a driving range with Tiki
Barber and uh he said you know where you
at I said hey I'm Tiki he said all right
he said
you could finally exhale again I got 11
years out full-time job and I said
what's up he said we finally got you a
full-time job I said
oh thank you my best friend God Almighty
in heaven thank you God and I said uh
with who he said CBS Sports they just
got the NFL back I said I'll take it he
said don't you want how much it's for I
said I don't give a [__] because I
validated anything more than this yeah
but when I walked in that giant locker
room day one I said I'll be [__]
different to everybody else and I'll be
the last dude standing it validated me
for what I set out to do correct
and I was [__] huge yeah it was I
still kind of get it but that was my
moment how the [__] did you survive 11
years I saw my body a lot yes did a lot
of privacy yes it was Strahan a guy who
always as he was an All-Pro as great as
he was I think he played 11 years
think about how long that is well I
remember first four he wasn't
and this is like Brenda knows I've
trained football players for years and
with martial arts and a lot of it was
from him was like I think it was Deacon
Jones and how he long had to talk with
him and said hey you don't play football
you fight and that game starts and you
[__] cage door locks you better make
that guy across from you beg to get off
that field and that click with Michael
and he went out the next year got 15
sacks never looked back is that right
yeah he just said okay it's a fight he
turned into it so did he always have uh
show business or something on his mind
because Tiki Barber did but it didn't
quite you know that didn't work he
should be the blueprint for all athletes
like what he's doing is higher level
than anybody else he's ever done and
here's the other thing people don't know
about him
like we're both trying to work on our
crafts him too he and I would do
appearances at like we would do like
synagogues in Long Island just to work
on public speaking for zero dollars yeah
people don't know that or when I was
doing New York on TV he'd come in and be
a guest at midnight I hosted a show
practicing practice oh what was it for
call unnecessary roughness it was a few
different radio stations for like well
it wasn't getting paid it was like WR
um
WABC but you got a free meal from it it
was a three hour show and I'd have a
different Giant and Jet coming each week
and host the show with me and Michael
was like the guest three-fourths is done
just to work it but three hour shows
without getting paid wow so people don't
see that exactly how much you were yeah
how much time he put in we both put in
that it's that work that you put in it
when no one's watching no one knows yeah
he's so good at it yeah he's so good but
even back then he would like
literally were in front of it while he
was playing synagogue where everybody's
like a cough away from a heart attack
and he's just [__] murdering it in
there and he'd have to be at practice
the next day yeah yeah and this was like
his second year we started doing this so
it's 94. damn yeah old school yeah yeah
[__] yeah he likes incredible that's
incredible be the Giants and jets were
you uh obviously you're probably more of
a Giants fan I grew up being giant fan
but then that went out the door when you
start covering them you're not paying
anybody you know yeah fan of everybody
really yeah yeah were you so uh not
surprised we know it was come but Aaron
Rodgers on the Jets big deal yeah huge
that's huge for them oh absolutely with
that defense because here's the thing
people don't understand about the Jets
they're not just competing with the
Giants no competing with the Yankees
oh [__] this everybody in New York is
competing with the Yankees and they
don't realize that it's not just the
Giants and jets there's the Knicks but
the Yankees so to get a guy like Aaron
there and make some extremely relevant
in that town but also when you get a
pissed off Aaron Rodgers trouble yeah
it's trouble trouble yeah they've done a
great job putting together the rest of
that roster that's doing a really good
job and drafting yeah yeah Savage yeah
ice Hall when he comes back in yeah I've
been to Jets games I've been to Giants
games in the stadiums yeah totally
different I was about I was about to ask
you it's a strange thing but there is
such a difference between Giants fans
and jets fans because giant fans have
won they're not as angry
Jets fans you see fights you see a dozen
fights because they always suck everyone
anything since name it yeah they haven't
had a good quarterback in the I don't
know how long Well Chad Pennington was
great but he kept getting injured he'd
be great for two games you might be the
only guy calls him great he's good yeah
yeah
Aaron Rodgers going there too
dude so excited how long has he been
playing now what's what year is he in
Aaron yeah
18. is that
um 18 years ago before yeah I'm gonna
say it's 18.
05. there you go five to twenty oh five
yeah he's played that long I had no idea
yep at that level remember he he sat the
first like 17 years so this would be two
three years he did because yeah Brett
virus that that in itself
because I was around for all that and
people don't remember like there were
fans boycotting picking and showing up
with signs wanting Brett Favre and not
Aaron Rodgers and the fact he was able
to
deal with that
I mean mental health-wise before we've
ever talked about mental health to be
able to deal with all these people just
hating them [__] on them as a young
and he's a kid back then 25 years old
and and you have a fan base showing up
with signs picking and hating you not
wanting you in and for him to go out and
just slice up the league the way he did
that makes him that makes power him
against man holy [__] I and that's what
you know they're kind of looking at
Jordan love them like nobody's gonna be
able to do what Aaron had done he's
unique he's a Hall of Famer he's one of
the best who ever did it and this kid
could be great but what Aaron did and
people just don't give Aaron enough
credit for being able to stand up to
that that kind of baptism it's hard man
that's but that's that's more that's
drowning that's you know you're getting
your head stuck in there for a while and
right early 20s yeah it's crazy enjoy
that [__] but you you talk about like
the mental aspect of the game in your
book you talk about unbreakable the
mental side I feel like it's become more
of a narrative now especially with
players yeah yeah big time you know and
listen I wrote my book
um because
like we talk about whole mental health
these days and the book is you know how
I turn my depression anxiety and a
motivation and you can too
um and I did use it like I wake up it's
an everyday thing I think a lot of
people in in fight World obviously a lot
of us in this business and football
we're [__] up going in right but we
never talked about it so I just you know
I built up this crazy character of you
know the glaze and having fun on TV and
being crazy and fighting a football is a
badge of honor but no one knew how much
pain I was in and it was every day of my
life I wake up and I wake up in
something called a gray and it's
literally every [__] day I wake up I
think the sky is falling I'm [__]
crazy and the roommates in my head are
telling me really bad things like
everybody hates me and everything's
against me it's hard for me to get out
of bed but it's been like this my entire
life I don't know any other way to exist
and it's normal so you you've always
been this way always since our little
kid on and man and the anxiety I've had
anxiety attacks every time I've been on
TV from 2005 on I've never not and I
don't understand why it happened first
one was an empty Raider Stadium and I
felt like I was having a heart attack
and it was weird for me because I'm I'm
great in chaos I suck in calm which is
why I caused a lot of chaos a lot of
times so I don't really know why it
happened there because it's chaos so
it's usually good but then it became
habitual and I just didn't know what was
going on like my hands were shaking my
eyes are darting back and forth I'm kind
of hyperventilating and I'm as I'm on
camera I'm dealing with this and I call
it wrestling with my abuser because I'm
kind of almost like negotiating with it
wrestling with your abuser wow just
leave me the [__] alone don't choke me
out here yeah not right now not right
now not right now until we get home wait
till we get home so you're talking to
the you're talking sort of to the other
side of the voices yeah and um but the
depression part like man I wish I could
have talked about this a long time ago
and so I'll give you an example like
with strand
um when I about a year and a half ago so
before I came out with this book but
like right before
um I started posting about like mental
health checkups each day just to show
everybody like again I'm trying to give
it words like we all talk mental health
but who the [__] giving it words who's
describing it so we can start having
this conversation yeah so in the past
when I'd have like I called the beast
getting out of the box and I have a bad
[__] night
um or just pop some Viking and drink and
go out and usually get in some trouble
and you know and and this night for one
night I was going out to dinner with
stray and I said man I can't go out
tonight he said well I said piece got
out of the box and I just need to chill
instead of dealing how I used to and he
said uh well [__] you want to talk about
it I said no not right now I'm really
beat up because also when I have bad
depression spell or anxiety spell I feel
it like in the left side of my gut my
joints start aching like crazy damn this
behind my ribs you were born with this
chair yeah childhood trauma yeah I think
it's everything like everything it's all
I remember so I don't really know the
answer that but it's my earliest
childhood memory and it becomes physical
it becomes physical yeah it's [__]
exhausting and he's shaking his head
right you get it and there's when I was
younger that my parents took me to many
they almost took my gallbladder out
because really had such a pain every day
it was after my brother passed wow every
day see that and right before surgery
they were like maybe not wait let's hold
off I was at the hospital in Chicago
look how cool it is that he can talk
about it now which we wouldn't have done
he lost 400 must be 400 pounds [__]
really that was 400 for you dude proud
of you man thank you but it's like he
wanted felt comfortable talking about
that a year ago no we would have made
fun of it right yeah
I had jokes in the chamber right now but
I was like
Jay when you talk this way because I
always I see you I've known you
peripherally I see you as a a bigger
than life guy who's always [__] like
at it you're you're a man
but when you talk this way it's in
possible not to love you a little bit oh
I appreciate it but you know what I mean
because when somebody's vulnerable but
it's really true when somebody's
vulnerable like this when you're this
because you're helping people I like I'm
I'm watching you and I I just have such
a deep life anybody that knows Jay knows
he's like this
Jalen I love Jay yeah is it great I feel
like you guys
forever
I should bring him in the train my
football players
[__] you making me do yeah like no
you're just gonna wrestle these 19
football players
but so so the story was straight I'm
like he's like you want to talk about I
said not tonight I just want to go to
bed I could sleep this one off and he
said you want me to come over at least I
said nope and he goes why have you never
told me I said I don't make the rules up
with this [__] dude I just know with you
I felt ashamed but he goes yeah but you
took away my ability to be your best
friend for 35 years wow I could have
been there all those years that's why I
wrote this book the question so we can
start talking to a straight hand
struggle from any of this he he
understands it he gets it but he doesn't
he no no I'll let him talk about that
yeah so
um but there's certain things now we
connect on that he and because now I'm
kind of I'm doing a lot of inspirational
talking on it how to get us through this
how do you do it and when I talk to him
about it he's like oh [__] man that
resonates with me that gets the guy
really with the most is the rock wrote
my forward
and he was like dude you're going to be
a voice for all of us in the gray we
can't talk about it and now he's
starting to talk about it so he like and
he didn't just like throw it away he
like really got deep in my [__] and
interviewed me over this and that he's
like I want this to to make a difference
for all of us you're gonna be the one
who leads it The Rock The Rock sometimes
um I don't know him I don't know but but
somebody who's always always going going
like his schedule's so crazy when I see
him laugh I don't see his eyes laughing
so so for me I always think that there's
something going on there's a depression
there there's something going yeah and
he's talking about it now yeah which I'm
proud of it because that's what we need
to do and then because I don't think
listen I don't think we're I'm in the
minority no right I think we're the
majority we talk personalities a lot of
times what drives you and it's
successful people you're all you can't
be successful and not have some crazy
Misfit right you've never met a comic
never met a comic Jay right it worth
their salt who who is normal and who had
a less than chaotic upbringing right
right exactly I mean am I wrong but but
think about if more guys are open and
talking about I always think of my
favorite player growing up who I modeled
myself a junior sale right right his
might have been CT but I think they were
he talked about it before he had a lot
of depression before even before that
he'd have a lot of depression yeah a lot
of pressure on from his dad like the lot
childhood trauma a lot of that is on
Junior sale where if it was now maybe
you'd talk about it maybe you know maybe
you could save some people and what I'm
trying to do with people I just talked
to the last year I talked to the Vikings
and Seahawks about this and I said
mental health is so reactive it's and
we're not proud of it enough you know
you break your arm we sign your cast
right I came in here right away and I
showed you guys my my in my MRI on my
back I'm like look how [__] up my back
is I missed my L4 L5 I'm all [__]
proud of this [__] right we don't do
this all right mental health we hide it
right so I said but you guys are the
only time we talk about mental health is
when the sky is falling we go to see a
therapist it's too late but you guys
don't just work work on catching balls
when you have the drops you don't just
bench press when you feel you're getting
weak you're constantly doing it so we
got to start doing this reactively the
problem is it's probably not enough
therapist out there for us yet they
don't trust them enough yet which they
need to which they're our coaches so in
the meantime I want to get us to lean
into each other and be our teammates be
our therapist I said think how much
closer this will make you guys if you
all realize you're all this [__]
together you all got it and you can lean
into each other on this weird for guys
we still don't do so weird right now we
don't do it we know each other yeah
we're as close as it gets but I don't
think because if you do this [__] we
weave a couple times but for the most
part we don't [__] we're doing work
it's like no matter what we're going
straight and I've been best friends
since 93 our relationship is never
stronger since we've been so what do you
do what can somebody do when they wake
up so here okay so when I wake up and
I'm having a [__] horrible day like
I'm just in my bed damn they're crying
like man just it's a hopeless
like I said heavy dark gray feeling
um I will immediately on those days I
will call four friends of mine
and it's the charades and the rocks and
people and then two other people
um and tell them because the more like I
don't feel like I'm fighting alone
walking this walk with someone it helps
out a little bit and then I'll call four
other people tell them you tell them
I'll tell them like [__] I'm struggling
today man the guy why I don't know I'm
just struggling today but even though I
could never do that but it's I'm telling
you to help me so when I'm on set it
probably helps me up on Sunday and I'm
having one I'll tell Kurt Menifee and
Howie Long I'll go [__] them having one
and it just to be able to say it
is it takes the pressure off me a lot it
helps out a lot because you don't have
to be I don't know
you can bring your shadow in there yeah
I don't have to walk this walk alone I
got there's power in numbers I got a
[__] fight team with me right but
then I'll call four other dudes and not
tell them what's going on me and just
check up on them
because one of the things I try to use
to get through this to be of service and
by me checking up with one of my boys
that's me being of service and it really
[__] helps me get through and you're
he's he's not yes again over here yeah
all right and just being of service
helps me so much whether it's charity
work or or just something simple like
this just telling somebody else and then
I'll immediately no matter what get
myself some kind of workout like if you
could take work out and put it in pill
form it'd be the greatest yourself is
there a way you talk to yourself like
when when you wake up and stuff um and
God bless your fiance oh my God so she's
dealing with your [__] no [__]
absolutely no doubt yes but here's the
other thing too I'm 53 yeah it's the
first time I've Found Love I've had been
you know married and well you were in
the world you were in the way probably
so much I was I pushed everybody away I
sabotaged because I felt I wasn't worthy
of it so they can't possibly love me
like this so I'm gonna [__] it up before
anything that's right this girl Rosie
Tennyson is the um is the first one and
like the other two weeks ago I had a
little meltdown and she was like hey hey
I'm not going anywhere like I'm getting
choked up talking about it well nice try
I'm like I'm not going anywhere and I
get choked up because that's like she's
like I'm not going anywhere
no matter what you can do I'm here I'm
here no matter what and that's the first
time someone's really got me and done
that for me and but my point is I'm 53.
so it's never too late to find them
you're never gonna use them yeah that's
that's like that's like what was your
childhood like though Jay your parents
yes yeah just non-stop chaos that's
right yeah I was gonna add those man
that's gonna [__] chaos
it was great too because my parents took
me to the therapist when I was like four
like I'm the [__] up one yeah I'm like
yeah
it's just chaos it's just your dad just
cast just businessman went to New York
every day and it was just chaos and um
I don't think they would look at it that
way but I know how I look at it yeah and
you know but it was also it's a chemical
thing and I've also been on here's the
other thing I've been on over 30 meds
and none have worked and like nothing
if there's anybody who should be a weed
guy it's me but [__] weed I suck at
weed me too oh man I [__] wish I was
great too right yeah yeah terrible [__]
I can't breathe in my neck I have
anxiety oh [__] yeah I know it's
terrible what about mushrooms if you try
something yeah yeah I've actually done
that with therapist and that has been a
game changer for me
um yeah I've done some some deep like
eight hour sessions with them that got
me to really see some things of why I'm
so [__] up
um but I like to say I'm [__] up but
I'm good with my [__] upness yeah 100
yeah you made it work for you yeah and
but that's the other thing too it's sad
if you're coming here like asking us for
money
then this podcast isn't cool right but I
know it's cool because you're success
Jay so close
it's not even his back he doesn't have
depression this is all you know it's
exactly it's a rude
how I've turned my depression anxiety
into motivation and you can too because
and then what this does also it gets you
feel so unloved so I didn't really feel
I could
Feel Love From the Inside Out so it
forced me and motivated me to go do all
this great [__] and to go 11 years with
without getting a full-time paycheck I
was so damn motivated to go do great
things to get some love from the outside
in and hope that one day they meet in
the middle and I could live a peaceful
existence and I'm I'm still working
progress I ain't I'm not there yet I'm
getting there you head the right
direction I'm heading the right
direction I think you need those demons
especially in the whatever [__] you're
in with us entertainment stand up
whatever it is sports you need those
demons it's a rocket fuel if you Channel
it right it's rocket fuel but at one
point we gotta take those monsters and
we're gonna put them in a box because we
deserve to be happy you know and I've
had some
um I've had some Spells Of Happiness now
since I've opened up talked about this I
do a podcast now every week where I get
to talk about this with people I had
Lindsey Vonn on this week and get to
bond with her about it and you know like
always been pretty open about her mental
health yeah but like comedians I have
Spade on uh in a couple weeks uh Freddie
Prince Jr on this week he's gone oh [__]
he's telling Richard Pryor stories yeah
definitely and obviously yeah his dad
he's a great guy on his own too he's
just he is phenomenal but this one
allows me to now talk and get deep with
people I never would and that's what I
need I needed like this and that's what
made my career I had these deep
relationships with people with people
with these football players and Fighters
for all those years and now it's with
everybody else and it's it's just a
deeper it's a deeper existence which is
cool well you realize there's a
community out there who loves and
support and you guys can talk about it
level two where you can relate on that
yeah how'd you get into like I'm a man
having a gym and so I had a couple
fights early early
um yeah a couple fights uh and oh
three I think and then
um back in the early days
yeah or no no no back then it was just
Style versus style yeah I didn't know
any Jiu-Jitsu I got my ass choked out on
my first fight because I have wrestling
background boxing book had no jiu jitsu
uh and then I was like well [__] I I
better go learn this [__] I don't know
what the hell a guillotine is and so and
went to henzo's and trained under Enzo
for a while and did some tournaments and
then my first day at Fox I came in I was
uh I was really busted up it was yeah
oh three two six I think okay so I was
there I was there 97.98 okay yeah so
um and I was just learning it how not to
get choked out so I could ground and
pound and um but my first day of fox I
kind of come in there was 04 and by then
I'd gone out to I forget when I was I
went at one point I was going to start
and joined uh Arizona Combat Sports so
like me Ryan Bader Aaron Simpson TB
dollarway Jamie Varner a whole bunch of
us real wrestlers and it was yeah it was
great and uh yeah
um eventually like Carlos conda tell us
latex was staying there then too no Kane
had gone
he was wrestling at Arizona State but he
went right up to San Jose
um and then so I come in Fox my first
day and like my eyes shut my [__]
ribs are busting my foot is broke and
this and that and David Hill the
chairman of Fox like [__] happened to
you and kind of telling my eyes shut and
he's like oh I don't know what this
thing is you're talking about but you
will never [__] can do it again
well I'm clearly not on TV for my looks
then I realize I am on TV for my life
but I but as you know like you can't
stop it I have a broken nose but you
can't stop like it's it kind of
institutionalize you and you just I felt
different I felt special those bonds I
had you know my training Partners ended
up being the Randy coutures and the
Chuck liddells and you know the
chelseons guys like this and but it's
those bonds that you have and this is
really where I started talking mental
health after we beat the [__] out of
each other we sit in a cage and that's
when we open up to each other yeah it's
the best times right and that's when
you're most vulnerable and like no one's
questioned our manhood you start talking
about it oh yeah but I couldn't stop so
I'm like all right well
I can't stop I love it I love the bonds
there of these fight teams I better
learn how to do something else and I
started learning how to coach I learned
that from Randy I had a coach and
um and I realized back then I'm like
okay if I can coach the fighter
mentality and the fighter grind the
fighter violence to these football
players but then take the sport IQ from
football and give it to Fighters then we
it's a [__] great trade-off because
no one's watching film back then there's
nothing you know I mean besides Randy
but man they're like I would sit there
with Strahan all night long and he would
film film film
and hours and hours I'm like what are
you [__] watching he's like look look
right here look at John Runyan's foot
how it's out you know three inches
turned to the right on run plays when
they're gonna bootleg out here and I'm
like the [__] are you looking at he's
like look look at the Lester Holmes the
guards elbow has a slight twitch
dude it's unbelievable so I learned that
from them and taught it to Fighters and
then Wow have the wrestling fighter
mentality to football players and then
just kind of you know change things
around so we would work on hand violence
and leverage and again we did a billion
hours of pummeling with these guys to
teach them leverage and like I said I'd
you know Brandon come in and yeah coming
out for a little bit and he's like [__]
you Glazer
is there uh yeah I always wondered like
the level of athleticism in the NFL
obviously is just so stupid but it's the
violence too it's like right you can
you know the guys that that really get
it the Andrew Whitworth and Lane Johnson
some of these guys they [__] play
forever because they get it because they
make it a fight and they just make it
you know the Ray Lewis make it violent
every [__] place
totally different level right there's
like that you can go on forever but
they're they're like I don't think I
don't really know but I I've heard him
talk like the what it takes to be in
that fight on a football field where
you're the answer rate is a hundred
percent you're always something's always
wrong and you're in a real but it's not
worse than fighting fighting you you can
go in a game and come out of a game yeah
and like okay I'm exhausted fight every
time you're gonna fight you're gonna
come out Something's Gonna Be Different
about your body forever 100 forever
is the best MMA fighter than Amy's ever
seen playing in the NFL right now in
other words without athleticism yeah
that's what makes John so but it's more
than just athleticism I feel like
fighting John if you put him through a
combine would do awful correct awful
that's right he's just his IQ the way
he's doing right but he's outside like
for the sport correct yeah but that's
why
and that's why I try and tell these
football players most of these guys are
signing up for sport they ain't signing
up for a fight right so if you're making
a fight different most of these guys
across for you they're going to tap out
yeah and that's where like our guys too
like [__] don't put your hands on your
hips don't show your tire if you watch
Andrew Whitworth he would go in
everybody goes in in the Huddle right
Andrew if you go back and watch film now
he would only dip his right ear into the
Huddle because he'd look at everybody
else and see who the [__] has their
hands on their hips he was huffing and
puffing and they'll turn back around
tell hey let's go with that guy let's go
with that watch Aaron Donald for the
Rams it is a [__] fight yeah really
yes and he's dominated
with a helmet I think he's like six feet
280 pounds yeah yeah but he is he makes
it every single play he makes it a fight
and he doesn't give a [__] about getting
the quarterback he just wants absolute
mass destruction of anybody in front of
him every play so like if you're sitting
there practicing funny because like last
year they decided they have to like tell
him like Hey we're going to give you a
rest as a veteran rest but it's not
really a veteran rest they're taking him
out for a couple plays so they can have
a real practice
think they're way better than they are
everybody else thinks they're better he
[__] practice up that much he's that
dominant yes so you have to have a real
practice when he's not in it's not real
when he's in there I guess he's not
disrupted the first guys you've never
seen anything like really his hands guys
like him and Dominic and Sue and those
guys
yeah he's different though than
everybody really yeah yeah I've been
here well you know yeah
what's his name um Hall of Fame
linebacker for the uh Falcons um enough
for the uh Baltimore uh oh Ray Lewis Ray
Lewis yeah same thing I mean Walmart
wrestler right [__] a wrestling
background he just oh he was arrested
yeah he was a wrestler too but he also
has that he has that every single play
he'd go back over and he would it'd be a
new fight for him every single player
but also yes like his mentality Taylor
yeah absolutely so oh dude I got to
cover Lauren one year I was gonna say
because he's a giant yeah that was great
it was awesome it was just
that motherfucker's different he was the
only guy I've ever been around my life
where if you
with martians came down and there was a
10 000 of us in the room they would look
over and go okay that fucker's different
yeah yeah he was just different did you
see his comments when they're like hey
your sack records can be broken and he
goes what because it doesn't count you
see him at opportunities they have today
he goes I want I want you to look up how
many sacks I have right how many
opportunities I had compared to how many
of the kids I don't understand it's a
Passing League yeah and they protect
everybody yeah 30 times more again at
least and they protect you also so it's
like the rules are different so it's um
I remember one time dick for a meal
telling me he said man there was a game
we were playing against Lawrence and we
had four schemes just specifically to
stop him
yeah maybe the first one beat the second
one beat the third one beat the fourth
one four sacks he's like uh I don't
really know what else to do yeah
I think the quarterback for the Jets or
whatever was miked yeah and so yeah
somebody's gonna stop yeah and he jumped
over the half back the hat back he's
like I remember he goes who's gonna I
think they're talking in a quarterback
or someone says who's gonna who's
blocking Taylor yeah and he goes staff
back and you hear the quarreco no he's
not right that's what I know he jumped
over no no no and that's and he didn't
really train he didn't work out no God
blessed him no he's just it but he had
who else
Bo Jackson well he was ridiculous Bo
Jackson never lifted weights I talked to
him about it he said I never lifted
weights I would just strap it on and go
in there and like hear them go both in
the game he was when I worked with him
10 years after he's playing I don't know
what it was he was still six two two
forty five and just almost I did an
appearance with him yeah he blew out
that hit but Howie Long's like that's
the freakiest most freakiest guy ever
been around my life yeah I was around
him when he was playing dude how he has
a story Howie is one of my best friends
and how he's also like and I read this
in the books I
part of the thing I do for my own
depression and [__] is play jokes a lot
because I like to laugh so laughing
we're talking about comedians
um
laughter I always say the gray hates
laughter so I'm always trying to laugh
and [__] around but Howie like
everybody's afraid of so I would like
he's like my muse like I play so many
jokes on him it's like I put one time I
put a bumper sticker on his car like
this [__] big I love porn and he just
drove around Beverly Hills it's [__]
Howie Long right and then that's [__]
he's talking about Beverly Hills he
finally comes back in and people he goes
people are honking at me and they give
me a thumbs up he goes just think
because I'm Howie Long like nobody will
put a bumper sticker on how he lost his
car like this right and then I got him
again I can't say it because not
politically correct enough oh I got him
again and he calls me he drives his car
in the Beverly Wilshire and it's a
really [__] raunchy bumper sticker
it's really bad and this black tie event
is getting out and all of a sudden they
come over and they're like taking
pictures of his car and the doorman over
there or boy Drew is like Mr long any
chance you were Mr glazers today he goes
you know what oh [__] he looks over and
there's this bumper sticker and he calls
me up he goes do you leave another Bubba
shark on my car I said
mom who is this he [__] I drive him
crazy or like he's scared one year I
found out that guy one time I found out
like our assistant like what his flight
info was he was flying commercial so I
like waited to know exactly when he was
in his seat and you know those like
really bad like anybody everything else
that [__] where if you turn on it's like
a bad porn someone's like screaming and
you can't stop it yeah so I [__] send
him that and he's sitting there in like
first class it's like ah yeah God he's
trying to turn this [__] phone off
and he's sitting next to an old lady up
there and he's like what happens if
that's the last thing like the plane
goes down that's the last thing that
someone said I said not my problem bro
why are people afraid of him because
he's usually kind of sick and how we
long yeah but what you see is what you
get he's a bad [__] absolutely
his kids are bad his kids are bad but
they also can like can't believe you do
that [__] to Dad I'm like he's gonna
beat me you ever hear him talking about
his dad like Howie Long I think he beat
his own data all right we won't get into
his dad oh yeah oh really
he told the story I'll let him tell but
there was one time I was training Kyle
yeah and kind of long
um and our old spot despite you came and
trained at right and um so we're kind of
like going over hand violence with Kyle
so most of these linemen they're used to
kind of open handing right so I'm like
instead of Smashing guys forums open
hand let's Hammer Fest yeah right teach
like a hammer fist that Fighters use on
your form so it's same thing with like a
little leg kick attack those nerves over
and over and over and over and over and
you know I don't care how tough you are
eventually you're gonna get that grip
right so we're going over with with Kyle
and Howie like but he kept butting him
cut button in kept button in I'm like
how you're like [__] Honey Boo Boo's
mom just sit over there and let me
[__] work with Kyle if you can bring
him here and uh he kept buttoning I said
Howie let me show you we're doing also
and I go and I [__] oh [__] and I crack
how he's four
a crack is formed with a hammer Fist and
he goes
why the [__] would you do that why and
he goes and he gets like
his car key and he puts it in here in
between his knuckle and [__] tries to
punch me in the eye with his car keys
it's [__] Howie Long and like I cause
pain and he's gonna [__] me up and you
know what he put his car key right in
the middle of his [__] Jesus his two
fingers and try to [__] tag me in the
face with it yeah so how is how he's no
joke no no joke no joke no he's like
he's another guy who's
um I I worked I did a thing I didn't
work with him but he was in when I was
doing Mad TV We were in New Orleans and
he was helping us do some bits and stuff
and I remember just being in the same
trailer
I just couldn't believe how big he was
like his jaw like he just looks like
like a cartoon character and his hand I
shook his hand he had this I think a
Rolex on you know you just feel like for
your guy built like me just feel like
such a [__]
how did he played college ball Villanova
oh wow small town school too tiny yeah
yeah but he was too he's naturally 280.
yeah he's just he's told like he's still
the same size yeah and uh why did he
stop being he was being a movie star for
a while he was starring yeah once he had
um kids starting oh he's like he's like
uh yeah broke an hour and Firestorm we
give him a lot of [__] over those
um but he just want to spend time with
the family yeah he's like that's it I'm
gonna like Keon he's the best dad so you
know I I adopted my son and
I learned how to be a dad from him like
I literally like I don't know what [__]
I was doing and then like you learn from
Howie yeah like he's such a your doctor
your son a man when he's two well that's
cool that's on Sammy yeah I think you
met him right yeah I met him yeah and he
you just decided to adopt the uh I was
with her mom and then we split up I was
going to want to be with him and so I
dumped him after we got after we split
up and he's just he's my dude that's
cool man it's awesome that's amazing
but I know what the [__] I was doing so
I literally like looked like turning
like how many how are we really both his
kids play in the NFL two of them two and
three two of them yeah yeah the other
one yeah
just play the same position
bro he is the meanest nastiest [__]
dude you will ever be around like that's
who you want that's protection
quarterback Kyle
yeah the only one that didn't play in
the NFL is the Howard Howie see look at
look go down to Kyle does he not look
like a cast off from Taken
for any of his boxes in his stomach he
is the strongest dude who's ever put his
hands on me in my entire life oh yeah
yeah and I've trained
oh man we've trained [__] I don't know a
thousand athletes over over the course
of all these years
and uh he is now but man he's a Slimmer
now yeah he's a mean [__]
it's exactly who you want protecting
your quarterback yes Jesus so he so he
went to Oregon uh he played like four
games and was the 20th pick of the draft
he was also the number one pitching
Prospect in America left-handed pitching
Prospect went down to Florida state for
a full ride and left there ended up
playing football but he we have a uh
again so you see the size of the [__]
guy so it was there's a uh there was a
Saint Patty's Day week he comes out and
he would stay with me when he was in the
train and he would be my sons Manny uh
stay with me it'd be Sammy's Manny and
it was great I trained him it was
[__] fantastic he's my little brother
and so he's flying back out and he's
gonna stay with me for a little while I
said all right I'm put this bar over in
you know West Hollywood we always hung
out called Rock and Rollies and um
um I said communist rallies and just
drop your [__] off at the house come
meet us there he goes great so I said
Sammy's there go mess with Sammy for a
little bit come meet us it's all said
I'm sitting here at the bar and Kyle
calls me and he goes you moved
I was like [__] did I not tell you he
goes to my old house kicks the door in
and he's like Sammy where are you
[__] it's like these two old
people there and they're like no no your
friend don't live here anymore
and he's like so you know Sasquatch
comes kicking in the doors
he's new Korean come on Jay and he's
like no he's like an older European
couple and but he's like they had like
the old phone with the wire with the
cord and they're like we're gonna call
police now and he's like I don't know
what accent I'm trying to do but uh but
uh yeah that was uh that was his third
son do uh it works for the Raiders okay
awful great dude great dude he's done an
amazing job at home him and Diane
they're incredible like I said I learned
from them so it's it's pretty that whole
thing the whole Squad incredible yeah
yeah it demands Excellence yeah how is
he yeah Chris won a couple Super Bowls
that's it you know yeah that's right
that's kind of crazy yeah chances think
about the chances of that just getting
into well if your dad's how he long you
come from that genetics like you look at
do you uh do you still train a lot of
guys getting ready for like Pro days and
stuff nah no and I stopped with the
combine guys because you were doing that
for a little bit for a while yeah and I
kind of like
I think guys it's just changed where
back then
like now listen being famous ain't the
same as being great
and
a lot of them think it's the same thing
and everybody's famous now because of
social media but they haven't done
anything they haven't done [__] yeah
they don't really have the desire to do
it because they're famous and Rich not
good we're back in the day the only way
you got
famous Rich if you made pro bowls so
it's a different workouts and I want to
sound like the old grouchy guy but I'm
also my body on the line and I do all
this [__] I Pummel with these guys I do
hand fighting I box with these guys we
[__] do combo for combo Spar and [__]
like that and I'm like over time I'm
like man if they're not gonna try and be
the lane Johnsons and the and the Andrew
we're with some guys like that I don't
[__] I don't I don't think I want to put
my and Couture was doing it for me with
me for a while and then Randy had a
heart attack in the gym so that was who
he did you ever heard this no really no
do you hear about that one yeah I've
heard yeah yeah no you're a full-blown
heart attack in the gym and uh and so
gronk's in the gym working out and he
we're doing MMA and chest and he started
feeling it during the workout he
finishes the workout and all of a sudden
he something's wrong he gets home and
he's like [__] something's wrong he runs
to Cedar Sinai because he didn't want to
deal with parking
okay that's Randy Couture right that's
right yeah it's like the anti-uber ad
right here right yeah so he runs the
[__] Cedar salad I get the call he
has a full Widowmaker heart attack and
you know that is fully like when you
have a compromise in your area well full
blockage yeah full blockage so he has
like 15 minutes to live is what they
told us so gronka's like man
I see what you're talking about like
with this MMA program you have here like
if I can get someone like Randy has
behind his rib cage and put in me I'll
be unbreakable I said well hold that
thought because what he has behind his
rib cage he's about to [__] explode
again
I come [__] racing down to Cedar sign
I I had a bad both my lungs aspirated
during a procedure before I open
unbreakable and I woke up at Cedar Sinai
and Randy was at my Gurney and
oh I was there I [__] woke up there
he's in my Gurney I'm like well
if I'm dead I ain't in heaven because if
I was his [__] ass wouldn't be here
yeah so so I'm like I got to be there
for him yeah so I come [__] busting
through post-op and boom I'm I'm not
waiting for them to tell me I can get in
there and I come breaking through and
he's like he's fully awake he's they put
a stent in he's like all right I'm good
to go I said there's like 15 minutes out
I said we didn't mean you're going to go
I guess yeah I'm ready to leave I said
well let's not leave let's see what's
going on here and he goes no I'm good I
said [__] that's not first of all I'm
glad you're live because if you died
we'd have to change the name of the gym
to breakable it's not a good place yeah
it's a bad brand right yeah so he goes
no I'm good to go I said [__] dude let's
just hold on here and and meanwhile the
doctors have told us like a billion
times he's fighting days Rovers training
days wherever I go hey don't [__]
tell them that like so don't take away
this whole price just shut the [__] so I
started getting after the doctor it's
just no one [__] come here and tell
them again that he almost died and all
this [__] just
get out so
a little bit later he starts sweating
kind of loses color I'm like hey you're
right there dude and he goes I don't
know something's going on so we bring
the doctors in and I'm like don't tell
them they don't die and all this [__]
and first thing they said and um
he said what's your uh
what's your uh pain level at right now
and he goes yeah it's about a two and I
go you can't ask this [__] guy was
paying level yeah right so he goes he
goes they go what was your I said you
can't ask this guy with his pain level
is he different than the rusty hole and
they said what was your pain level at
the height of the heart attack he goes I
was a little worse I'd say I was about a
four so I go wait
I said Randy broke his arm against
Gabriel Gonzaga right I said what was
your pain level like at that he goes
didn't [__] hurt it was a broken arm
it was just pressure that says see doc
that's what you're dealing with yeah
that's what you're doing yeah so a four
to himself a billion for us yeah yeah so
three weeks later comes back and
unbreakable we throw him up we're glad
you didn't die party
and um
and all of a sudden he goes into office
he [__] comes out he's fully geared
up
I was like what are we doing here he
goes come on let's go I said dude we're
not doing this like let's you're three
weeks out of a heart attack he goes
let's go let's gear up I said bro he
goes only thing is I'm on blood thinners
but that's not your problem that's my
problem sounds like bro he goes I would
do it for you
you was like oh right yeah right oh [__]
he's just slowly still working out we
went in well Randy's we went in bro
the [__] round ended he didn't stop
second round at it we didn't stop
they're rounded he didn't stop he just
kept going and going and he just
the the style that we that we coaches
from him it's just Relentless just on
you on you on you you don't like the
pressure is a as a weapon and man it
just it was [__] one of the worst
sessions ever happened Randy would break
people oh absolutely that's the whole
that's unbreakable and it just doesn't
stop doesn't stop so we finally finished
up like four or five rounds
he takes his gloves off throws them on
[__] ground and says hey [__] those
doctors walks out of the cage and
proceeds to coach for another five hours
it's Randy Couture yeah he's different
it's like your general doctor assumption
so glad he didn't die just for business
purposes oh man and if he was about to
go hey did you say you're at 24 Hour
Fitness or something oh man
how old is he now Randy was like 104.
yeah 60. he's he's 59 40 59 Legend right
yep there you go handsome son of a [__]
yeah he's different man he is he is a
different guy just a legend but he's the
best man same thing he is one of the
best friend to ever had me is he still a
little dude is he still involved with uh
not not really right like his son's not
really fighting anymore yeah but his son
he I think his son took over extreme
Couture Randy's kind of retired up to uh
Flagstaff he's doing the acting thing
yeah he's great yeah it was awesome dude
that
he's he's the best man Terry Crews
that's that's enough well then it was me
him and Chuck too so we would work out
together don't say that one right
towards pictures on the screen
I know for Washington yeah
that's that's not well once the greatest
had a cappuccino with the Chargers no he
wasn't like an All-Pro okay no
no no no no no no yeah no Randy is Randy
yeah yeah we're already [__]
different yeah yes come oh I mean with
everybody so there were one time two
were in the gym and Sloane's like hey
I'm gonna uh I gotta kill Randy off with
Expendables I said you can't do that
he's a what do you mean I said that's
our guy you can't do that he goes you're
[__] telling me
because I [__] train with you and you
should ask Jim I can't kill off one of
my people I go exactly he goes
I got an arm off I said as long as he's
alive yeah he's great tell him he's okay
he just did another Expendable [__]
friend of the year right here hell yeah
damn right damn right dude
man you paid his mortgage that's a big
deal
jeez that's pretty awesome you can't
kill them all like who said Jake laser
oh [__] you want to get some current
events yeah
[Music]
if Dana were to leave the UFC he's the
guy for the job really yeah what's he do
now though or the commissioner or the
president or yeah I would vote for him
for president he he uh we should be the
governor of California yeah he went on
got his Masters
um he uh he was we were broadcasting the
UFC together at Fox yeah crushing but
like I don't know who he was in a
previous life but I think he was like
Jonah Salk and like God has blessed him
with his life coming forward it's like
he's incredible he is incredible crazy
human being got the Silver Star from
President Bush
um went on WC land heavyweight champ of
the world and he was great at
commentating too and really comments
played football in Annapolis yeah
incredible yeah like he's done
everything stud yeah it makes me feel it
nice to get a great dad too incredible
dad yeah great he just got remarried in
uh Malibu and that's where I saw oh [__]
yeah and then I moved to Malibu as a
result so you moved out there yeah yeah
I was living in Arizona moved out near
with my girl love it yeah it's great out
there brother oh it's fantastic I'm out
there all the time are you all the time
where are you gonna hang out where are
you at in Malibu yeah
yeah I love it out there all right Tim
what do you got yeah shout out to Brian
Stan definitely
um so first of all a friend of the show
jelly roll he'll be performing on
American Idol I don't think and so jelly
roll he did that uh performance with
Lainey Wilson which was incredible yeah
yeah he did his huge song his number one
song which one saved me but you don't
realize how big time jelly roll is now
because American Idol people make fun of
it I watch it every episode but for him
to be the feature on the finale American
Idol it's usually like Katy Perry uh you
know Shakira JLo it's [__] our boy jelly
roll I know dude you know with tattoos
on his face it makes us get drunk with
them it's on American Idol that's great
it's insane sweetheart I text him last
night I'm like bro American Idol he goes
you watch her go do I am that's why I
was like I want to make sure you knew
but yeah obviously yeah I mean they were
texting last night yeah nuts up so
insane dude so did you watch it at the
CMAs with that Lainey Wilson yeah I saw
the clips that's good yeah
she's freaking killing it right now too
anyway everyone she had a great quote
she goes uh for all you dreamers out
there you got to be a uh uh a doer
because everyone has dreams the
difference is I like it I grind it I'm a
doer not only am I a dreamer I'm a doer
so I had the dreams but I put in the
work to get to my dreams that's awesome
yeah everyone's gonna tell you to dream
but you got to do it absolutely yeah
take action it was a great message yep
I'm like a lady I saw a couple episodes
recently American that girl sang the uh
the uh Whitney Houston song oh nuts oh
my God it was unbelievable nuts yeah
that's crazy I like the big Hawaiian
dude yeah everyone loves it yeah yeah I
don't know if he's gonna win because
these things someone I've heard Hawaiian
song every time all he does is the wines
I'm like every week though that's his
only thing he's like no matter what it
is it's like pop culture week no he's
singing you know the Hawaiian [__] he's
only in Hawaiian is that Guitar ukulele
is it's got to be you crazy but he's so
big yeah
but it might be a guitar yeah
he's amazing he's the one I showed you
with his videos his dad dying yeah oh
geez yeah his dad passed away so he
stopped singing then his mom submitted
his video no yeah I missed all that oh
bro oh wow
he's huge so yeah he has to be 400
pounds oh yeah Six Strings so I think
for me that's an oversized guitar yeah
yeah yeah
all I can think about is pancreas that's
like when I was surfing because I'm so
big you know my board's huge people yo
you're paddle boarding I'm like no no
that's it that's my circle son of a
[__]
uh So speaking of Music this is not that
new but so Ed Sheeran remember who's
thinking out loud songs sound a lot like
uh Marvin Gaye and The Marvin Gaye
family was suing him yep here's what's
interesting did you think no I didn't
think so the beat is almost identical
but Ed Sheeran's case was so smart so
good because it it's like a chord
progression chord pattern but he but he
showed examples of that so many other
songs
a lot of music uses the same I didn't
steal from a lot of people use these
same progressions what's interesting
before the trial he goes if I'm found
guilty in this I'm I quit he's like I'm
out because it takes the inspiration
away and I was critical about this too
because I thought it sounds so yeah what
no no but I was just like you know you
played it first I remember yeah but I
mean yeah anyways he won so that's
beautiful that's great he was a judge on
American Idol he was great yeah dude
he's lost a lot of [__]
and that that's where I tell people too
like if like you don't have to have my
level depression anxiety for you to be
going through gray because first of all
Instagram makes us all think our lives
suck We compare ourselves to everybody
else's filtered filtered fraction of one
second 15 seconds of their day and
they're like man look what he's doing on
Monday like my meal doesn't work like
that look like that how come I don't
have that car why am I not at that part
I feel so [__] left out yeah fomo
right all the time or if we feel like
losers like man look how great these
people are doing it's not real or on
like Twitter like look we got our ass
kicked in the playground growing up that
sucked for like a month but now we see
it a thousand times a second on Twitter
every day and like the human condition's
not meant for that so yeah it's like no
the studies on that are gonna be nice
man like suicides up for a reason mental
health is the worst it's ever been I
think it's a straight can compute
contributor to social media and the more
that comes out listen I'm a confident
dude you know I don't suffer from
depression sure I go through spells and
stuff but I don't have like a clinical
depression that gives me depression out
I post and ghosts yeah on Twitter I
might comment back here and there other
than that I post and ghosts I don't look
at anybody else's [__] people calling me
like what do you mean like uh I'm trying
to stuff now that I'm like what are you
up to man he's like oh dude I just
played the beacon I sold out I'm like
how would I know that yeah social media
I'm like I'm not on I don't look at it
like you do man I call him like tell me
tell me what you're doing yeah like
don't make don't assume I know because
of social media just because we're
successful don't mean our feelings don't
[__] hurt yeah my wallet is not an
antidepressant that's right yeah there's
this idea that because you're a quote
unquote celebrity right you you your
fair game and you don't hell no I'm more
emotional than most what's got me more
I'm more sensitive right absolutely yes
no it's [__] terrible man right
awesome your life I think to be
successful at anything your life is a
lot of times less than glamorous if
people can see what life is really like
on a movie set I like the amount of
hurry up and wait and [__] and you're
also just sitting there eating like
you're there 16 hour days all day and
you're on some roof somewhere eating
from places but even a job like when
like they see you you know break this
big news story and then I felt like
massive news story they just see that
like you have no idea he was up all
night yeah
like no one's filming that no no you
want to do video when you don't have
something yeah well that did yeah they
want to stop with the highs and lows you
go through yeah I was talking to
somebody's like yeah man movie stars
they live that you know you got that
[__] everybody they're doing parties
all the time I go do you ever been
around real actors who are working talk
to people who have to wake up at five in
the morning every day it's just all
works for hours
the rejection you'll have to go through
over and over and over and over and over
so you don't show anything people don't
know that I said 11 years seven yearses
yeah in in 25 years seven years they
were good a lot of [__] rejection but
for real but that's acting that's seven
good guesses I swear to God somebody
said I was doing this thing I said um
can you tell us about success it was
time I was doing the Goldbergs where I
was doing in school or whatever and they
said can you tell us like how do you
become successful and I said successful
at so I'm 50. I was 53 at the time I go
all right here's what you do you sit in
traffic for your 20s and 30s and even a
lot of your 40s hearing the word no and
then you'll get seven yeses and just
hold on that's all you're doing that's
all we'll talk to Michael's like no
one's was following his career the first
four years right right like I would love
to see Michael there yeah
that was a great experience too yeah and
you saw it and I was and then it was
um all of a sudden boom he gets you know
15 sacks and gets contract it's on TV
and he and I used to go to the same
[__] places every single night for
for those five years the first five
years and all of a sudden
all those people who are sitting there
were all coming to our table offering
them jeans company after Gene's company
record label after record label somebody
offered them ostrich Farm to invest in
Strawberry pick and feel everybody has
the next Napster back then yeah for the
next Myspace and this and that and I'd
be the no guy I'd sit there and I go hey
man this look like our office too you've
been sitting there for four years I
haven't said [__] and all of a sudden
you see them get paid on TV yeah now
you're trying to get his money you got
to go and we'd have this good cop bad
cop thing and then I had the same thing
with Chuck and Randy made it you know
known them before they meant all of a
sudden same thing happened yeah or the
rashads are all those people said nope
everybody's trying they're good friends
running your table yeah
damn right they all tell you I tell
everybody don't invest [__] just use
your name and get mail money and
everybody out of the same male money
what do you mean like let them send you
money in a mail for using your name and
like this yeah but if you don't invest
your own money you can't lose it yeah so
everybody have the same thing they say
listen we're going to give you two
percent of this but if you give us 500
Grand we'll give you 10 imagine if you
had 10 percent of Facebook instead of
two percent and I'd be like uber two
percent bro yeah yeah we're okay no risk
yeah yeah and that's where guys get in
trouble
it's funny because athletes want to be
businessman and businessmen want to be
athletes so they all want to kind of get
their athletes around them so it was a
really good experience for me to have
and then yeah that's cool I was able to
kind of live up myself someone I've
never invested in a thing really yeah
well the first question asked those guys
would be how much of your money do you
have in this yes yes yeah right how much
can I see that right right right right
yes 500 Grand do you have do you have
500 of your own your money you [__]
[__] well she got you all right this
is pretty scary MLB
have you seen this uh pitcher get hit in
the head with a 19 mine drive seven yeah
19.7 miles per hour yeah I'd love to see
it okay real quick
it was so terrifying
he was able to walk off the field but he
did suffer a fracture that's not it hit
him
fractures called like a small fraction
skull and obviously a concussion damn
but
you can die you looked all right though
yeah he was able to walk off wow more
concerned about those terrible Rockies
jerseys
he's walking off there but I mean you
know who knows how much damage it's
gonna be yeah later on so
Jesus I hate that oh and they put him on
the injured list for like 15 days which
I thought was kind of small short but I
don't know you're probably all right all
right
um should we do this one
let's do this one okay so Brian I
remember you mentioned this last week I
think about a hotel manager who snuck
into someone's room and sucked their
toes like at 5am another dude too I
don't I don't know why that's weird but
dude it's so weird you don't know why
it's weird no apparently I'm kidding oh
really apparently didn't apparently it
just came in robbed him and then what's
up managers charged us or like he's
sucking us even gets toes
amongst other things 52 yeah so the guy
now is suffering from the uh the guy
that got his toe sucked is suffering
from PTSD and suing this guy
look at Brian's yeah fans kept on
sending this thing I'm sorry bro is that
spray paint yeah because when you know
what you look like in real life when
you're like people are saying it looks
like Brian for some reason right a
little bit great wait they spray paint
his eyebrows and beard yeah sure I've
worn that
look
they're all like
there you go bro guys here's two what
look at him that could be great
I want to play the music but I can't B I
think you either gotta do that or look
at Jay he just decided to change
it look at this guy great Bobby
oh no oh sick there you go that looks
natural terrible wig he owns the
Patriots
oh that dude
um
I don't know what else oh this okay so a
lot of people tagged Us in this as well
they thought Brian would like wow I'm
I'm into her
so she gets relaxed what seven figures
it's her face she's so pretty
she's a little too jacked really bro
okay so I went to her Instagram she's
too much testosterone
the Kendall Jenner on steroids her name
is Vlad de Salva Galligan yeah but the
zero Instagram
yeah I'm not into the steroid thing I
like a muscular woman but no that's
that's I'm a fan of but that's too big
in the arms and she's just yeah dude
yeah I know she is I've seen her you do
yeah she's Brazilian
is she Brazilian I believe so yeah
yeah that name's not very Brazilian B
yeah but she is though
but uh yeah people thought you might
yeah she's just counting style all day
well I'm gay so obviously
um okay so this is the yeah how about
this dumbass yeah NBA dumb boy so this
is the second time he had a Instagram
live or whatever and showing a gun and
now he could potentially be suspected
his friends who were putting us on
Instagram live if he's gonna carry a gun
around the Polish should be no social
media like if I'm in the car no why
would his friend post this but after you
got suspended why would you ever I know
and he went through all the protocols
and all the the suspensions so he's he's
losing tons of money because he's in all
Pros they didn't vote him all pro
because of this outside the who needs
some help the field
it's it's nuts yeah so now he's gonna be
suspended who knows how long yeah
Bill Burr has an old he's been
controversial joke about this where did
they suspend him already you ever hear
Bill Burris joke about this like they're
paraphrasing and he'd be like a lot of
these black athletes need a white friend
so you can be like hey dude you know you
got a gun slide in the back seat there
yeah
but yeah it's uh but what his buddies
like you know if this gets out he's
screwed man his buddy just wants clop
probably so yeah whatever that's not
your buddy are your friends yeah follow
your friends that's his problems right
come on guys seriously oh him too he
can't be pulling up a gun what are you
thinking yeah and also you know whatever
he makes 300 million a year could you if
you're worried about guns and stuff
could you not hire security well hold on
what's going on here so apparently Kanye
West uh did a trademark for they're
called uh easy socks shoes yeah I know
those are rash guards that's not easy
because that's an elite logo those are
straight up I mean
yeah that's all it is because it says
that's hilarious yeah he's wearing Muay
Thai right so it says I didn't realize
that yeah you just sprayed paint black
straight up shin guards and who's this
gal that's his wife his new girl wow
yeah she's cool she's hot
man usually Fair Tech's coming soon okay
yeah if you're a fan of Yeezy do you
copy this style it's just this is his
old this is in 2019 another version like
the sock shoes but I mean like if you
walk in there
yeah yeah they were and those are ghee
pants well you can check he's always
doing this continuing from us
is it weird man yeah that's him though
easy yeah let's see if it picks up at
all
oh yeah those are
that's pretty cool yeah
so he's wearing the wheel
shouldn't try to say it's his fashion
this [__] is hilarious
right now I mean why not the tiger
wrestling shoes oh my God maybe he's
wearing the elites but they're just
saying in the article he's trademarking
the sock shoes and maybe this is the
only picture they had she is wearing
shin guards out in public yeah and
that's the kind of shirt you wear when
you wrestle and you have to lose water
away yeah you know what I mean that's
the kind of shirt you wear when you're
in high school when you have to lose
weight
I don't know about this yeah maybe he's
fighting he just left practice we don't
know
what are characters
what an absolute character
who is the who is his wife she's um
she's the head of uh she's a fashion
right something yeah yeah and she looks
like when she had long hair black hair
she did look like Kim Kardashian I like
her hair like that mm-hmm
is that it chin that's it
Glazer go buy his book unbreakable thank
you brother yeah mental health I'm gonna
read it thank you podcast podcast two
yes right what's the podcast called
unbreakable mental health podcast Freddy
Freddy yeah I really appreciate you
coming on and talking about Freddie
Prince Jr is coming on this week I
absolutely love him man that's cool man
I appreciate it man that's good to see
you guys I know brother it's been a long
time I gotta hit you up from Alabama
absolutely dude yeah yeah same number
same number I can't ever change my
number because like I've gotten stories
from guys like 10 years later yeah like
you know try to give your scoop and
stuff you just can't change your number
I used to have two phones because I
thought the Patriots and the league were
trying to and I had the uh video I
thought they were uh
they were tapping my phone did you break
the Spy game yeah I still have it before
we go can I just ask one question is Tom
Brady really getting into stand up
I didn't see that yeah I don't know if
that's real yeah I heard that from more
than I can't see that really neither can
I but they said they said he's turning
down the fox deal to get in the stand up
like he's a smart guy I don't think you
don't have to okay you don't have to
turn down Fox to get stand up you can do
it at night yeah it's also Monday
through Saturday yeah yes it doesn't
make those headlines yeah
maybe I'll try it but he's not gonna
turn down though he actually he opened
up tb12 in in our gym unbreakable so
we're doing his uh yeah that's cool yeah
he's trying to buy into the Raiders
right a minority owner that TV 12 dude I
tore up my labrum Alden Smith who I
trained to come back to the NFL and uh
man he tore my labor and
kept trying to kept trying him like a
dumbass and they just cut it out and
they they went in the surgery they cut
out the labor and they they didn't
reattach and it was
the MRI didn't show it to like they went
in for a scope and they ended up being a
three and a half hour surgery two days
before start of the Season kind of being
on TV and so the doc's like looks you're
not gonna throw a ball anymore or do any
military press and I had to go out and
throw out the first pitch of the
Diamondbacks game
four pitches in I was like oh [__] he
was right like this [__] just sublexed
out it was awful and I was like man I
started to throw the pitch and I was
like man just don't bounce it I don't
want to be surbounced a lot and it was
[__] terrible and I went down to
Tampa and Alex Guerrero his guy he's
like am I gonna lie to you it's Gonna
Hurt put it back in and then worked on
it and it's been great ever since oh
damn I haven't thrown a baller down a
military presence but she was no joke
you know I'm sure you're the same way I
don't really listen to doctors no no no
no no yeah I'm like they don't know what
they're talking about I'm Different
I think they're paying attention to med
school come on please is all Smith still
playing the NFL he's in jail right now
he is yeah so he he just uh again yeah I
love the dude though man a guy like that
too and a lot of these guys he just
they don't think they're Worthy
of the success they sabotage because
they're like I'm gonna [__] it up anyway
which is what a lot of us do I'm gonna
[__] it up anyway so I'm gonna speed up
the process
part of my charity it's just
everything's just [__] great dude
he's great how long he was in he was out
for four years I met him he was homeless
and trained him got him back got him
back signed to the Cowboys and um was
kicking ass for a while and then kind of
fell off the wagon but yeah that's such
a shame yeah man I believe in second
third fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth
chance what's your talent like that yeah
but it also is hard it's not a good
person he wasn't trying to play in the
league again he was just wanted a place
to go give a team again transition well
he was living in sober living when I met
him she was homeless in limited to over
living and then um he just fit the gym
great it was great he was he was humble
as [__] with everybody loved him man I
still love him yeah yeah I love that you
said that you believe in fifth sixth
seventh absolutely you're a good [__]
dude people are giving me a billion dude
I I've had a lot of issues and meltdowns
and stuff and it's hard to be Jake laser
friend sometimes so
you're
by far a much you're a great person back
then but you know
you're a much better person at 53. thank
you brother and uh and I think that's
the that's the goal to evolve into a
much better person yeah we love you man
thank you brother go buy his book
yeah I'm moving in yeah you give me my
kiddo Caleb laughs